saleté se tourne se tourne ce tour
bonjour à tous et bienvenue je suis ravi
de vous retrouver une nouvelle fois en
face caméra pour aborder un sujet un peu
sensible l'afrocentrisme c'est quelque
chose que j'avais déjà vu le gars ise
par le passé notamment sous un format
conférence c'était aux historiques de
montbazon de mémoire c'est la première
conférence que j'avais donné dans tous
les cas je vous mets cette vidéo dans le
petit on va essayer de réfléchir dit à
ce sujet en fait aux conséquences de la
colonisation sur la manière de faire
l'histoire de l'afrique et en
particulier chez les descendants
d'esclaves aux états unis
[Musique]
l'histoire classique a longtemps vu dans
le continent européen le berceau de la
civilisation tant du point de vue
intellectuel que technologique
cette vision est ce qu'on appelle un
ethnocentrisme c'est à dire qu'elle
prend pour critère de jugement et
phénomène lié à une société en
particulier les chercheurs européens ont
donc fait au 19e siècle de l'invention
de l'état nation et les sciences
expérimentales le degré le plus abouti
de la civilisation
en prenant ces critères rien de plus
facile l'europe occidentale était de
très loin supérieur aux autres régions
du globe
un peu comme si usain bolt choisissez
d'évaluer les gens selon leur temps au
100 m pas très fair play
cette vision est bien entendu critiquer
par les anthropologues depuis belle
lurette et a fini par être abandonné il
n'est plus question aujourd'hui de
classer les civilisations sur une
échelle de l'évolution complètement
subjective
selon quelle danse la valse plutôt que
le zouk mais cette vision de l'histoire
centré sur l'europe sommet de la
civilisation humaine a laissé des traces
en particulier chez les anciennes
colonies européennes
en effet cette supposée supériorité
naturelle de l'europe était le principal
argument avancé par les colonisateurs
pour venir occuper et exploiter les
territoires d'outre-mer la colonisation
était censé apporter les lumières de la
civilisation à les peuples primitifs
rester dans l'obscurité les populations
entières ont donc appris que leur
culture et est arriérée et devait
changer au plus vite pour coller aux
standards de la modernité
l'histoire des sociétés colonisées a de
ce fait longtemps été ignorée
caricaturer ou carrément effacé par des
colonisateurs convaincu de l'infériorité
des autochtones faire l'histoire des
territoires colonisés
c'est donc essayé souvent de réparer cet
affront et de retrouver ce qu'étaient
les sociétés avant la colonisation de
gommer son influence au moins en partie
c'est dans ce contexte postcolonial
qu'est né le courant de pensée qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui l'afrocentrisme
l'afrocentrisme est un courant de pensée
en sciences humaines qui a pour but de
renverser une histoire jugé trop
européocentrique en faisant une lecture
des événements historiques centré sur le
continent africain
c'est donc sur le papier une entreprise
salutaire un effort pour rétablir un
équilibre un peu plus juste
le plus connu de ces théoriciens est
sans nul doute le sénégalais cheikh anta
diop qui a véritablement initié ce
renversement cet intellectuel engagé
dans la lutte pour la décolonisation a
donné son nom à l'université de dakar et
s'est fait connaître notamment par son
ouvrage nations [ __ ] et culture
c'est dans cet ouvrage qui date de 1954
qu'il est le premier à revendiquer une
origine entièrement [ __ ] je le cite de
la culture égyptienne antique et à faire
des cultures d'afrique noire les
héritières naturel de ce passé glorieux
cet ouvrage est ce qu'ils ont suivi
comme antériorité des civilisations
[ __ ]
mythe ou réalité historique sont à
l'origine d'une théorie diffusio nist
qui a fait long feu
je m'explique le diffuse ionis mme est
une théorie très simple la diffusion
c'est le fait que les cultures pioche
des techniques et tradition chère
voisine pour les adopter on a dans
l'histoire humaine des centaines
d'exemples de diffusion d'éléments
culturels l'adoption de l'agriculture
par des chasseurs cueilleurs ou celle du
christianisme par les romains par
exemple mais en croire cheikh anta diop
et d'autres auteurs afrocentriste
l'egypte antique serait non seulement
une civilisation authentique mont noir
mais aussi le seul vrai berceau de la
civilisation antique l'origine toutes
les diffusions culturelles l'egypte
aurait ensuite transmis ses
connaissances à la grèce la grèce à rome
et au bout du compte
l'europe aurait donc été civilisé par
l'afrique noire faute avec c'est un pied
de nez assez magistrale au colonisateur
le contraire en somme de ce qu'on
apprenait à l'école coloniale
malheureusement pour diop cette théorie
est très fragile
alors l'objectif de cette vidéo n'est
pas de démolir une théorie vieille de 70
ans qui n'a presque plus aucun écho dans
les universités mais il faut tout de
même dire deux mots des arguments
avancés par diop
premièrement il est impossible de
prouver que l'egypte antique était
peuplée uniquement de population noire
avant la conquête par les romains puis
par les arabes il y à bien la mention
par l'historien grec hérodote au vème
siècle avant jésus-christ des égyptiens
avec le mot grec mais là qui peut être
traduit par foncer et qui a donné
mélanine mais c'est assez faible pour
bâtir toute une théorie d'autres auteurs
plus récents comme théophile obenga
insiste sur l'utilisation par les
égyptiens du terme kenneth qui signifie
le pays noir pour parler de leur patrie
or les détracteurs de cette théorie
affirme que cette expression pourrait
aussi bien être comprise comme une
figure de style
l'adjectif noir d'écrire est ici le
limon noir extrêmement fertile déverser
tous les ans par les crues du nil et qui
était à la base de l'agriculture
égyptienne cela revient un peu à dire le
pays du cèdre pour parler du liban si
vous voulez c'est la fameuse vallée
l'insolent de fertilité vous vous
souvenez ça c'est pour les vrais sa sas
et ceux qui suivent ça c'est ceux qui
sont abonnés qu'on cliquez sur la petite
cloche et qui ont regardé la vidéo des
peuples de la mer voilà je vous laisse
rattraper un voilà enfin les études
génétiques sur les momies réalisé grâce
aux progrès de ces dernières années pour
prélever le génome endommagé tend à
montrer que les populations égyptiennes
étaient bien plus proche du moyen-orient
que de l'afrique subsaharienne à prendre
avec prudence cela ne concerne que
quelques centaines de personnes des
classes supérieures de la société
mais c'est un indice important bon il
est donc pour l'instant possible ni de
prouver que les égyptiens étaient noirs
comme l'affirment diop ni de dire qu'il
ne l'était pas en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que c'est pas clair passa à
passer ça est-ce qu'on n'est pas sûr du
mauvais goût deuxième affirmation de
diop ensuite
l'egypte serait le berceau de la
civilisation mondiale il est vrai que
les égyptiens de l'antiquité ont formé
le premier grand état centralisé et bâti
des trucs pointu culminant à 140 m 2
mais si on le chipoter on sait
aujourd'hui que les premières
agglomérations l'écriture et les
premières traces d'un pouvoir
administratif viennent toutes de la
région du croissant fertile quelques
centaines de kilomètres plus au nord-est
et pas d'égypte on va donc oublier les
thèses farfelues des héritiers de jobs
qui imaginent des égyptiens traversant
l'atlantique en 650 avant jésus-christ
pour aller fonder les civilisations
mexicaine
parce que sinon les gars on n'a pas fini
essayer de prouver que l'egypte était un
pays noir et qu'elle a civilisé le reste
du monde est une démarche militante
une démarche biaisé puisque elle
retourne en partie dans les travers de
l'histoire européenne qui le critiquent
c'est l'afrique et non plus l'europe qui
constitue le sommet de la civilisation
humaine
mais le raisonnement est le même on juge
les peuples voir les races selon leur
degré de civilisation et l'antériorité
de leurs poils technique les théories de
diop et de ses successeurs ne sont donc
pas tant à retenir du point de vue de la
recherche scientifique mais davantage
pour leurs conséquences dans les
sociétés et je voudrais parler
maintenant de la porte ces théories
afrocentriste dans les luttes pour
l'égalité raciale
[Musique]
laissons donc de côté l'archéologie pour
nous intéresser à la réception des
thèses afrocentriste les théories de
cheikh anta diop qu'on vient de décrire
et de critiquer rapidement son passé
dans le grand public reprises et
assimilés avec plus ou moins de détails
par l'intermédiaire d'autres grandes
figures universitaire et militante
c'est le cas aux états unis en
particulier pendant les années 60 dans
un contexte très tendu de lutte pour les
droits civiques émeutes urbaines et
lynchage par les terroristes du ku klux
klan se développe aux etats unis une
pensée afrocentriste même si elle ne se
nomme pas encore ainsi le premier qu'on
peut rattacher à ce mouvement et le
militant ron everett qui prend le nom de
maulana karenga pour revendiquer son
africanité
il est le fondateur du nationalisme
culturel afro américains en multipliant
les références à une afrique mythique
qu'il cherche à réaffirmer lisez les
esprits pour modifier l'identité de la
communauté afro américaine et lui
permettre de s'émanciper
il crée notamment en 66 la fête du
kwanza souvent appelé le noël noir qui
connaît depuis les années 90 un grand
succès commercial
un autre universitaire militants mollet
fia cents et adopte lui la théorie de
diop sur les origines égyptiennes de la
civilisation et l'a popularisé aux états
unis à l'université temple de
philadelphie il parvient même à créer
tout un département d'études afro
centriste mais sa volonté de régner en
maître sur ce courant de pensée génère
des divisions et ce pôle universitaire
fini par péricliter
d'autres chercheurs qu'on peut regrouper
sous l'appellation de mai la liste
soutiennent eux des thèses ouvertement
raciste
la mélanine la substance responsable de
la pigmentation de la peau est selon eux
la substance à l'origine de la
civilisation
il opère donc un retournement extrême du
stigmate historique contre les noirs et
affirme que la race blanche et
naturellement inférieure une vision
radicale sans s'attarder forcément sur
ce dernier exemple on peut dire que de
manière générale les démarches
afrocentriste dans le contexte des états
unis s'inscrivent dans un cadre de
revanche de réparation histoire le
combat porte en fait sur la
reconnaissance d'une forme de dette
morale des européens vis-à-vis des
africains ces mouvements deviennent
l'une des composantes de la lutte pour
l'émancipation des noirs aux états unis
et s'ils ont leur heure de gloire
il reste le plus souvent très
minoritaire comparé à des mouvements
comme celui de martin luther king ou des
black panthers avec lesquels ils
s'affrontent régulièrement
les études afro centriste ont créé le
débat à l'université mais se sont petit
à petit effacés plus qu'une contre
tradition scientifique adoptant des
théories excentrique l'afrocentrisme et
plus tôt aujourd'hui un mouvement très
diversifiée en fonction des lieux des
individus et des enjeux on voit
apparaître de nombreuses vision des
choses parfois antagonistes ce qui
subsiste n'est pas un mouvement
structuré et plutôt un ensemble de
pratiques souvent mouvante et qui sont
des leviers d'action pour la lutte ou
simplement pour se forger une identité
pour conclure on peut simplement rappelé
que l'afrique est un immense continent
mais qu'il faut s'intéresser aux
histoires africaines puisque l histoire
africaine au singulier comme s'il
existait une forme d'unité intrinsèques
les études historiques montrent la
complexité des échanges entre les
sociétés africaines et avec l'extérieur
et on ne peut jamais se satisfaire d'une
explication unique
par ailleurs les penseurs afrocentriste
ne se résume pas à chaque anta diop
même si c'est souvent lui qui focalise
l'attention il ya d'autres écoles
historiques qui font du point de vue
africain le centre de leur réflexion et
qui ont souvent été occulté par la
notoriété de certains militants l'oeuvre
du burkinabé joseph ki zerbo mériterait
à ce titre d'être réévalué son histoire
de l'afrique publié en soixante douze
s'attacher à replacer les cultures
africaines sur le même plan que les
autres en prenant en compte leurs
évolutions sociales économiques et
politiques
une démarche plus discrète mais
peut-être aussi plus juste vous l'avez
compris ce sont des questions très
complexes où se mêlent l'histoire la
psychologie des convictions politiques
et cette vidéo n'a absolument pas la
prétention de brosser un portrait
complet de toutes les démarches
afrocentriste il y as pour ça des
ouvrages qui donne bien plus de pistes
et que je vous ai listé en barre d'infos
je remercie d'ailleurs sarah fille là
bas kabadio maîtresse de conférences à
l'université de cergy pontoise qui a
pris le temps de répondre par mail à mes
questions pour préparer cette émission
son ouvrage africa and my mind a aussi
été très utile et il est l'un des très
rares livres en français sur ce sujet en
attendant la prochaine vidéo je vous
invite à poser vos questions en
commentaire à partager cette vidéo si
elle vous semble utile et puis également
vous pouvez me rejoindre sur instagram
je vous dis à la prochaine
vous embrasse salut africains on my mind
[Musique]